The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So what I want
to do is continue
talking about risk.
We've already talked about risk
quite a bit last time.
And what I want to do partly
is sort of emphasize some
specific points and, I think,
partly go over some of the
ideas that have to do
with a community
sharing its own risk.
So rather than risk through
formal insurance markets, talk
about what happens if people
try to insure each other.
And what that does is it creates
a nice context for
thinking about institutions in
general and the fact that
people live together, how that
might actually change their--
I think it's the display
settings.
I think we need to move to--
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So how the fact that people live
together in one place and
have to deal with each other on
a long run basis, how that
affects the ways in which they
can structure their economic
lives to help each other.
So it gets into a question
which is beyond, I think,
moving us beyond what we'd
usually be talking about,
which is individual decision
making, towards a more
collective action kind
of perspective.
So we want to slowly move
towards not just what happens
at the level of the individual,
by why doesn't the
collectivity together generate
good outcomes?
And this is a good in
to that question.
So we're going to talk.
So I'll give you a set of
examples of collective action,
and we'll start talking a bit
about the collective efforts
to improve things.
I'm not sure what's happening.
But we'll figure this out.
So the first, just to remind
you, we were talking about
risk and, in particular, the
fact that poor people face
extremely high levels of risk.
I said that yesterday, and
today I'll show you some
numbers on that just to
get us on to that.
Just to summarize where we were
last time, what we talked
about primarily were sort of
both that the poor face a lot
of risk and that they do a lot
of things to mitigate risk,
but those things are not
necessarily good for them.
So the examples we talked about
or, for example, going
to work when your income
goes down.
But when you go to work when
your income goes down,
typically that's when
everybody else's
income also went down.
So they also all go to work.
That drives wages down
and makes everybody
potentially worse off.
And the second example--
what's another example of a
costly thing you could do to
mitigate risk?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Farm separate pieces
of land that are far apart
from each other.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Farm separate pieces of land far
apart so that they don't
have the same risk profile.
AUDIENCE: You could choose not
to take a crop that might be
more successful because you're
worried that if you spend
money to buy new seeds and
it doesn't turn to be as
successful then you loose more
money than if you just used
your seeds from the
previous crop.
PROFESSOR: Any other?
AUDIENCE: Choosing a bunch of
different jobs instead of
specializing in one.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Choosing a bunch of different
jobs rather than doing one.
Why do you want to specialize?
AUDIENCE: It allows
you to become more
productive, more skilled.
PROFESSOR: So you give up--
sorry?
AUDIENCE: I was just going
to say efficiency.
PROFESSOR: Efficiency,
exactly.
You just get better at a job
if you do it more with more
[INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Like, if you were doing 15
classes [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 15 is
a high number.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I think you can see
the logic of this.
So the question is we already
talked a bit about kind of the
market for insurance.
What we didn't talk as much
about is why don't people help
each other?
One solution to this problem
is just helping each other.
So the logic of helping each
other is very, very simple.
We each get maybe independent
shocks and so it's quite
likely that, you know, when
somebody else gets a shock, I
don't and vice versa.
So we can kind of
split the shock.
So if anything bad happens,
we don't bear all of it.
We can pass on a part of
it to somebody else.
That seems straightforward.
So why doesn't that solve
most problems?
That's sort of the question that
we're going to spend some
time thinking about.
It's a very simple
idea, right?
We don't need to go to
an insurance company.
We can just pool together
our own risk.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
like, the cost of living
[INAUDIBLE] cost?
Like, how many people are
you going to pool
together for that?
And sometimes people think that
they shouldn't have to
pay for someone else's--
PROFESSOR: How many people
should we pool together?
AUDIENCE: As many as possible.
PROFESSOR: Why as many
as possible?
AUDIENCE: Because then it's
more diversified.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if we think that--
so you have the example, the
probability, here, let's say
they have independent
probabilities.
Two people, they have a
probability of a quarter that
they both end up with
a bad shock, right?
What's that probability if
there were n people?
AUDIENCE: 1/n squared?
PROFESSOR: N squared.
Think about what were
the probability.
The probability is half that--
I think you meant the other.
You just inverted
the exponents.
It's 1 over 2 to the power n.
I think you're writing it in--
it's 1 over 2 to the power n.
So as n goes to infinity, the
number of people who get
shocks together is going to 0.
So that's sort of a
very simple idea.
So the question is why
doesn't it happen?
And that's sort of what we're
going to spend our time
talking about.
So it does happen.
The first answer is
it does happen.
So here's a nice,
nice example.
And it says something about--
actually, it's an interesting
example.
So it turns out that the way
to work in Nigeria, I don't
actually give you money.
I don't actually give you
money when something bad
happens to you.
What do I do?
I loan you money and in
particular if you're expected
to pay me back, I ask
for less payback.
If I'm expected to pay you back,
I pay you more than what
I was supposed to owe you.
So usually interest contracts
tend to be completely
inflexible.
You know, my mortgage
is quarter of 5.4%.
I pay 5.4% every year until
the market is paid.
That's not what credit looks
like in Nigeria.
In these villages you found that
the interest rate itself
is very flexible.
So I pay more than what I owed,
in some sense, when you
are doing badly and I pay less
than what I owed when you're
doing well.
That's a way to provide
insurance, but it goes through
this cover of a loan.
AUDIENCE: How do they determine
if someone has an
adverse [INAUDIBLE]?
You know, like, through
word of mouth?
PROFESSOR: Perfectly
good question.
We'll come back.
Let's come back to that.
I want to spend a minute,
before we get to that
question, on a more basic
question, which is why do you
think they do this?
Why do you think that they go
through this loan mechanism?
So then what they seem to be
doing is paying you more on
your loan when you do badly and
paying you less on your
loan when the payer
is doing badly.
Why does that make any sense?
What could be driving
that structure?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Because they know
that later on when they'll
probably be doing badly that
they'll get a break and that
it'll help them out.
PROFESSOR: But why don't they
just give them money?
Why through the loan?
The question here I'm asking is
why is it that I give you a
discount on your loan
rather than just
handing you some cash?
What is that pointing to?
AUDIENCE: Desire to
not to feel like
you're giving a handout.
PROFESSOR: So one possibility
is that you it's sort of a
cover, right?
That's an interesting idea.
It's a cover for I'm giving
you the money.
But it's not so much that people
are not seeing that I'm
handing you some cash.
They're seeing that I'm actually
paying you some money
back for a loan.
So in that sense it's a cover.
Maybe everybody else also
knows that you are poor.
It's not so clear that it's
so hard, you know.
You had a comment?
AUDIENCE: They don't want them
to think that, become
dependent on things like that
being free or, like, kind of
expect that they're going to
get handouts all the time?
PROFESSOR: Well, why would
that be any different?
I could always say that I'm
doing badly, and you'll pay me
more on the loan I gave you.
Why would that be any
different to loan?
AUDIENCE: Maybe because it
creates some sort of
dependence relationship between
the two people.
So if you have to agree to it
beforehand, the other one can
just say, well, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I will come
back to that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was just going to
say that it sort of sets up a
contractual agreement where when
I'm not doing well, you
help me out and when
you're not doing
well, I help you out.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You could also say
that if someone just gives you
money that's kind of expected
to get some of the money,
something non zero benefits, a
loan that you have to repay,
there isn't really a guarantee
how much of a discount you're
going to get.
You can't really take that
into account as well.
PROFESSOR: So what you're saying
is related to what
they're saying, which is that
one thing about a loan is
using the loan suggests that
this is making use of a
preexisting financial
relationship, so an ongoing
relationship.
The difference between my giving
you money seems to be
mostly that in a sense these are
people who already had a
financial relationship.
So it's the case that a lot of
these people, one owes the
other one money already.
And adjusting the terms of that
suggests that it's not so
much-- so in other words, it's
not clear that what this isn't
telling us is simply that the
people who have these
transactions are already people
who've had a stock
against each other.
So it's not the case that--
so it's, you know, you keep
count and say it's not clear.
So instead of thinking of the
loan as being a separate
financial product, one way
to think about it is
that we keep accounts.
And I've done you five favors.
You've done me three favors.
And the net is two favors.
And the loan amount really
reflects our netting out of
those favors.
So in other words, what is nice
about a loan is it's a
net I owe you or you owe me.
It's a net accounting device
for keeping track of who's
done who how many favors.
So by thinking of it in long
terms, it creates a natural
framework for thinking about
this as kind of a social
accounting device.
How do I keep track of--
like, maybe people also say,
well, I did you seven favors
and you've not done me one.
I have heard people say things
like that, so the same
psychology.
It's a good way to keep track.
Thinking of it in terms of a
loan makes it clear that what
you're trying to do is keep
track of an ongoing
relationship.
It's a stock.
I gave you 100.
You paid me back 50.
Then I give you 30.
Then you give me 200.
And when I add those up, every
stage, what I really care
about is not how many times
what happened but the net
amount you owe me.
And that's a good way to account
for the relationship
so we can keep track of am I
someone who owes you or are
you someone who owes me by sort
of counting that amount.
And that way we don't need to
keep track of all these other
numbers, whether it was 20
ones and 15 another time.
It's just one number which
kind of measures our
collective obligation.
And the reason that we would
like-- why would we like to
keep track of the collective
obligation?
Why does it matter that we keep
track of the collective
obligation?
AUDIENCE: I mean, it promises
them security, right?
PROFESSOR: Security for who?
AUDIENCE: I would say that in
the community because one
person who was taking thousands
of dollars from
someone else, I'd know that if
that person asks me for money,
I wouldn't loan the person
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So one advantage of
that might be that it kind of
summarizes my status in
the collective system.
So it may be that everybody
knows I owe you 50.
And then nobody will want to
lend me much more because it
looks like I'm just somebody who
takes money from everybody
and never gives them.
So it's a good way to keep
track of whether there's
someone who sort of tried
to beat the system.
But there's another even
simpler reason why.
AUDIENCE: I guess [INAUDIBLE],
which is
basically the same thing.
PROFESSOR: Speak up.
AUDIENCE: Just to be a way to
avoid moral hazard, which is
essentially basically
the same thing.
PROFESSOR: Why would they
avoid moral hazard?
AUDIENCE: Because it's an
accountability system.
So, like, everyone in the
community is kind of aware of
it's a way of keeping track of
it on a smaller scale at a
larger company.
For example, like, in the
city couldn't do it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's basically
the same thing.
But in some ways I think there's
an even simpler reason
why you may want to keep track
of it, which is simply it may
well be that I just knew
vis-a-vis someone else, he may
want to know, how many times
has this guy taken from me?
And I may want to just put a
limit to that because I know
that at some level
I'm going to die
in 20 years or something.
And so I'm going to say, look,
you know, if it's reciprocity,
so that the reason I'm giving
him is x, that he will pay me
back eventually, then I want
to know whether it's
reasonable to expect that I'll
get enough back from him.
So if I think that basically the
reason why I'm giving him
the money is because he will
eventually give me back the
money when I need it.
Well, if my future is 20 years
and I've given him $5 million
dollars, I'm unlikely to
get that much back.
So I want to know roughly where
I am in that transaction
because that's the only way
that I can kind of make a
rational decision about whether
it's worth continuing.
If my reason for being in the
relationship is that I also
think that I'm going to get
some favors from him then
knowing how much he already owes
me is a way to keep track
of how much can I reasonably
expect to get back from him.
If that number's already way
past anything then I don't
need to give him extra favor
to get more back.
At some level I'm just not going
to be able to collect.
So if there's some kind
of a rational--
so I might want to limit my
exposure to him because in
some sense I know that it is
never going to pay off to
invest so much in a
particular person.
So it might be a useful
accounting device.
So I think that Chris Udry,
who did this study, his
interpretation very
much was this.
They're keeping track of how
much they owe each other, that
everybody knows roughly I owe
this guy this much, which is
within reasonable limits.
It's not too much.
And, therefore, I can expect
to get it back eventually.
So this is a table from
Chris's paper.
And it's just a very simple
point, but it's worth looking
at the paper.
It's sort of striking.
So it's the monthly
interest rate.
These are huge numbers.
That's why it's worth
looking at.
The monthly interest rate,
when the borrower gets no
shock, he pays four percentage
points less per month.
That's a lot, right?
Four percentage points.
What's four percentage
per month compounded?
What's the compounded?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Close to 50%.
So that's like 50% off.
So you're getting, like,
4% per month less.
Now take a look at the number.
When the lender, he has a bad
shock, no shock, he charges
basically 10 percentage points
less per month than when he
has a shock.
Difference would be minus 7.5
and 2.6, is basically 10
percentage points.
But when he has a shock,
he charges 10
percentage points more.
So these are massive numbers.
I mean, those are, like, huge.
The interest rates just move
enormously suggesting that
there is actually substantial
resource transfer
that's going on.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is this like he
actually charges or the person
just chooses to pay more?
PROFESSOR: He chooses.
So we don't know that.
All we observe is that the
person pays that much more
when the lender gets a shock.
But the difference, just to get
the order of magnitude,
these are very, very
large numbers.
So these are substantial
transfers going on in both
directions.
On the other hand, there's
still 10% of a loan.
So it's like, you know, the
stock is much bigger.
So these people have an ongoing
ledger with each other.
And then they change that
number by changing the
interest rate by a lot.
Now, what's that also
telling us?
It's also telling us something
about the scope of this
relationship, right?
So if the way I'm going to get
my insurance is by getting
even a 10 percentage
point reduction in
the interest rate--
so let's say the interest
rate is 15%.
And I get 10 percentage points
off, but I owe you $100.
How much do I save?
I save $5.00, right?
I was going to pay you $15,
and I now pay $5.
The main point is that the
amount of insurance that you
can get through this system is
still very limited by the
amount of loan there is because,
you know, if I'm
giving you a discount on a loan
then that depends on the
loan amount I had.
So if the loan amount was $1
million then a discount on
that is worth a lot.
If these are poor people and
their net loan amount is $10
then the fact that I'm getting
a discount from the loan is
not giving me that
much insurance.
So the downside of thinking
about it in loan terms and in
principle, this could be
relatively small number.
So I think these interest
rates are high.
But they're not high enough to
turn a small number into a
small number.
So that's sort of one thing
to keep in mind.
We'll come back to this because
I want to talk a
little bit more about other
forms of insurance.
So one form of insurance we
observe is this loan.
And that has its advantages,
and it's a
nice accounting device.
I can keep track of
what's going on.
It has the disadvantage that if
I haven't given you a loan
then I can't help you.
It sort of goes through
this loan.
So if you only owe me $5 then
it's not going to be a big
transfer because you can,
at most, let off the
interest on the $5.
But the interest
on $5 is $0.50.
And that's not going to make
a big difference to me.
So in general that limits
the scope of the system.
And what I want to talk about
is a bit of stuff from
Thailand, which is different
because our colleague, Robert
Townsend, has been studying
these villages
for many, many years.
And I'll show you some data
from what he's collected.
And then we'll see that the way
insurance is offered in
Thailand is very different
in principle.
And so institutional form--
in Nigeria it's a loan.
In Thailand we'll
see what it is.
So first here's a nice table.
It's sort of a fact that I've
been saying many times.
It just says how much
risk do people bear?
So what this table is,
each row is a farmer.
They don't have data
for every farmer.
But two things to note.
One is look at the best
year and the worst
year for these farmers.
They're somewhat correlated
but not perfectly, right?
The best year for some
farmers was '85.
The worst year for some
The best year for some
farmers was '88.
The worst year for some
Why am I emphasizing
the correlation?
These are all within the same
village, within one village.
Why am I emphasizing
the correlation?
AUDIENCE: To emphasize that the
shocks are independent.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that there is scope
for insurance.
I can insure you only if we
don't both get into trouble at
the same time.
So the worst year for one farmer
is not the worst year
for the other farmer.
The second thing is look
at the magnitudes.
That last column is
the percentage.
If you look at the harvest
amounts, the best year and the
worst year, the differences
are massive.
It's just the amounts.
I just want you to
look the amounts.
The amounts are impressive
because think about you got an
income of 50 one year and
115 the next year.
Those are big differences.
Anything else that
strikes you?
Now, this may be difficult
to see.
But one thing that's interesting
is that if you
look at the--
it's not that the people who
have average less harvest, the
risk seems to be independent
of that.
So richer people seem to have
roughly the same risk as
poorer people.
So everybody seems to
be exposed to risk.
It's not that the rich people
have less risk.
AUDIENCE: How do you
define richness?
PROFESSOR: Take the maximum
amount of harvest, the maximum
harvest, the people with the
biggest maximum harvest
[INAUDIBLE].
This table is nice too.
It goes back to answering
the implied question.
What's going on?
What's the source of risk?
AUDIENCE: These are all
the same households?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: These are all
the same households?
PROFESSOR: No.
Yeah.
These are the same households
as the previous table, same
numbers, B35, 36.
These are the same households.
They all live in the
same village.
And this is asking why
did you face risk?
And, again, mostly it has
to do with weather.
Though, for some people, there's
one person who says
that insects is the biggest
source of risk.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't fully
understand how someone's best
year was also someone's
worst year, how rain
could be the problem--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Someone else want to
suggest the answer?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I think
it indicates that--
I think there's two
potential answers.
One, rain could be the answer.
Maybe some of these fields
are irrigated.
But judging by the variation on
even the wealthiest fields,
which presumably would have
the greatest chance of
irrigation, the fact that it's
still pretty big fluctuations,
that's probably not
the answer.
I mean, I think it's indicative
that there's other
factors at work other
than rainfall.
PROFESSOR: But they're saying
that it's rain.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I mean, maybe because
they don't realize.
I mean, I think if they realize
what the other farmer
was doing that [INAUDIBLE]
more successful, they'd
probably try to do it.
So maybe they didn't realize
that fertilizer-- and maybe
that they got unlucky and got
hit with a disease they
weren't able to recognize.
PROFESSOR: They didn't
realize.
That could be.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It could be
different crops.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So most of this explanation is
that some of them are doing
very different crops.
So it might be some crops
hate water and
others really like it.
Like, rice really
adores water.
But cotton or chilies
hate water.
So there are crops which you
get too much rain, you get
lower output and crops which
output is always
increasing in rain.
And so one possible explanation
is that they were
planting different crops.
So we both planted
the same time.
I'm planting a crop which will
hurt if the rain is bad and
will do well when the rain is
good and the other way around.
So that's one possibility.
The other possibility is that
they're just micro climates,
that the rain is sort of--
after all, what matters is not
so much rain as such but rain
at the right time.
So I plant on a particular
day.
My saplings have just come
out of the ground.
That's when I need rain, when
the plant is young.
And so it may well be that
the rain on those five
days was very good.
But then the guy who planted
later, he thought the rains
would be better in five days.
And then the rains were
really not better.
They were really bad.
So it may very well be that
there is either geographical
variation in rainfall within a
local area or just over time.
So I planted on a
particular day.
I needed the rain 10 days
after that when the
saplings came out.
I got the rain.
You didn't get the rain.
So I think both of those
are plausible.
So I just wanted you to
look at this because I
keep talking of risk.
But this is sort of a much
better way to look at it.
You just see the magnitudes of
it and the sources of it.
So I thought these tables
were very nice.
And what he goes on to do in
this paper is asking how do
people deal with risk?
And so he's describing three
villages very close to each
other, to the point where one
of the villages, people
actually use the financial
institutions
in the other villages.
So they're very close
to each other.
They're exactly in this
area where the
rainfall was measured.
So the risk is roughly
what you saw.
So we got a sense of the risk.
And in Nigeria we saw that
people respond by borrowing
from each other.
Here, in this particular
village, there are five
different funds.
So there's a village
savings fund.
And the village savings fund
is actually an equity fund.
These guys actually pay you
a different rate of return
depending on what the borrowers
were willing to pay.
So I put in money
into this fund.
And then you come and borrow.
You're willing to pay 20%.
Then that money gets
rolled back to me.
So it's a fund which has a
variable interest which
depends on the village
demand levels.
What do you think should happen
to the interest rate in
that fund when the rainfall
is good or bad?
How would it pay?
Will it go up when the rainfall
is good or down?
AUDIENCE: Won't it go up because
people are willing pay
more [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So one possibility it
will go up because when the
rainfall is good, productivity
is high.
People are willing to buy
more inputs to produce.
Is that good for insurance
or bad for insurance?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's good for
insurance because the people
who are getting high
productivity shocks are borrowing.
But you would imagine the
opposite, which is a fund with
a variable interest rate where
we only borrow from it when
we're desperate.
Then you might see the demand
for those funds being
particularly high when rainfall
is bad because we're
all trying to borrow from
that to survive.
And at that point, very few
people are going to lend.
The interest rate is
going to go up.
That's going to be bad
for insurance.
So it depends very much.
Rather a fixed interest fund,
a variable interest fund can
be either good or bad
for insurance.
Then there is a fund for
purchase of pigs.
Here, the interest
rate is fixed.
But there's a rollover
provision.
Rollover provision is if you are
in trouble and you can't
pay, I can let you keep
the loan for longer.
You pay more, but you don't
have to pay back now.
Is that good for insurance
or bad?
AUDIENCE: Well, it depends
on the person
that they're insuring.
If the person [INAUDIBLE]
they can keep rolling it over
and eventually drop out.
But it could be good if the
person is experiencing some
transitory shock [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Assuming that the
person is going to pay it
back, it's good for insurance.
Rollovers are good
for insurance.
There's a fund for purchase
of fertilizer.
So each of these is almost
like a proper financial
institution at the
village level.
So in this village,
the leader has
organized a bunch of funds.
And you can save money to
buy pigs in this fund.
And right now if I've saved
money and you want to buy
pigs, you can borrow
from this fund.
And, likewise, there's money
in a fund for buying
fertilizer, a rice bank where
the rice I grow I can store.
And when I need rice, I
can take rice from it.
And there's a health care fund
where we each put in money.
And if somebody gets sick,
he gets to spend it.
So this is a village which
is rich with financial
institutions.
These are not loans.
In particular, the health care
fund or the rollover is
something where I'm making a
direct transfer to the people
who are hurting.
But it's not bilateral loans.
These are kind of financing from
a financial institution.
So the main point I'm making
here is that here you see a
very different sort
of insurance.
This is organized through
collective action.
Everybody's getting together and
lending to everybody else.
Now, he goes down a few more
miles from May Wak to a
village called Sop Wak.
And what does he see?
Well, on paper it looks
very similar.
But here's the problem.
All the loans are in default.
Not all, but a lot of loans
are in default.
Is this good or bad
for insurance?
Anybody else?
Why is a default bad
for insurance?
AUDIENCE: Because then the
people who are putting in the
money won't get any money.
PROFESSOR: But maybe the person
who is defaulting is
the one who needs to not pay.
It's so clear that default
is bad for insurance.
The problem is with this default
then nobody will put
money into the bank.
So default is, in a sense, a
form of insurance, right?
I allow you to not pay
when you can't pay.
But if there's a lot of default
and I think that's
mollified then I may not put
money into the bank.
So, again, it's not clear
which way it goes.
But he interprets this as saying
that these places,
these banks, nobody's putting
money into them.
So these banks are
kind of defunct.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How could it default
and not repay?
PROFESSOR: Oh, we could imagine
a world where that's
exactly how we provide
insurance.
So we each imagine
that the rule is.
Year one, if you have a shock
this year, you borrow.
Even year two, if you again have
a shock then you default.
We write it off, happens in
one time out of 10 or
one time out of 20.
But, you know, it can
happen to any of us.
And when it's really bad and
I've had two shocks in a row,
it's better for me to not have
to pay back than you to give
me yet another loan.
There's no particular reason why
default would be bad for
insurance if we could
make sure that
the default is limited.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't the insurance
company just loose
all that money though?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But it counts into its--
the insurance company is
losing that money.
But remember, when an insurance
company makes a
payment, it also loses money.
So just think of it as
a form of payment.
Default could just be a form of
insurance because I could
be paying people in the
form of default.
You don't have to pay.
Fine.
You don't have any money,
you don't have to pay.
That's a perfectly legitimate
form of insurance.
Just the question is whether
it's deliberate, in which case
there will be too much of it.
And in that case the
system won't work.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: That may be the case
when there's an insurance
company or a government which
is writing off the loan.
But the latest census
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I guess a lot is
relative to what they're
willing and what they
were planning for.
There's nothing else about
a lot of default.
It's just what you're
planning for.
I could plan for, you know, one
loan out of five will be
defaulted, and the others will
just absorb that loss.
It might me fine.
It may be a form of insurance.
Default is a natural
form of insurance.
That's a way of understanding.
There is nothing obviously
bad about default if it's
completely just I
have no choice.
I default.
That's a perfectly good way to
insure myself because then I
don't need to pay when I'm
in really bad shape.
It's when I start using as an
excuse to not pay that it
makes a difference.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think I'm getting
tripped up because usually
default is when the intent is
for you to get that paid back.
So if you're using default as
a form of insurance, to me,
it's no longer default then.
It's just a form of insurance.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I kind of agree with that.
I mean, that seems like we're
arguing over words.
So I think default just means
I don't pay the loan.
And when I don't pay the
loan, that might
very well be desirable.
Now, as you see, their view is
a bit that it's not actually
necessarily a good idea to
collect because they're taking
the view that these people are
defaulting because they need
to default.
So it's not clear what
default means here.
And that's worth
understanding.
Then he walks down to
a third village.
The third village is
a few miles down.
And none of these funds exist.
So one village, all the funds
are working well.
In the second village, there's
lot of default.
The funds are still there.
Third village, no funds
except one.
And you are in the Nigerian
mode where you're just
borrowing from each other.
So what's the advantage
of a fund over
borrowing from each other?
Let me see if someone else
wants to answer.
What's the advantage
of a fund over
borrowing from each other?
AUDIENCE: They have more
resources for you to borrow?
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: One individual has a
limited constraint, whereas if
people pool their
money together.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's a way to pool many
more people in.
So that's the advantage
of a fund.
So what do you think
is going on?
Why do these villages, which
are very similar, have same
kind of risk next to
each other, have
very different patterns?
Think about what it takes for
such an institution to exist.
AUDIENCE: They need the trust
of the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the way one of these funds
works is by saying that I'm
going to put money into it now
because I can get money into
it in the future.
What does that assume?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's going to
exist in the future.
PROFESSOR: That there
is a future.
So in other words, if I think
that everybody else is going
to default today, I should
default as well because there
will be no fund in the future.
So this is a classic kind of
problem of anything that's
sort of sustained
by the future.
It depends on there
being a future.
So this is the problem that
right now a lot of microcredit
organizations are facing.
Microcredit organizations
promise you a loan if you pay
back your loan.
Now, suppose you think that
nobody else will pay back
their loan.
What's going to happen to the
microcredit organization?
It's going to go bankrupt.
If it goes bankrupt, what's
going to happen
to your future loan?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't exist.
PROFESSOR: It doesn't exist.
So basically if everybody
expects people to default in
the future then I should
default now.
So if everybody else is expected
to default, it is
rational for me to default.
If everybody expected to pay
back in the future then it's
rational for me to pay back
because then the fund will be
there for a long time.
So I think this is sort of
the reason why funds--
so all of these kind of informal
institutions are
fragile because they rely on
this kind of coordination.
I only want to repay if
everybody else wants to repay
or at least as long as enough
people want to repay that the
fund will be going.
If I expect that lots of people
will default in the
future, I should default now
because the fund is going to
go out of business.
I'm not going to get anything
out of it in the future.
So I might as well just stop
having anything to do with it.
So it totally depends
on trust.
If I believe that everybody else
is going to behave well
then I should behave well.
If I think that everybody else
is going to behave badly then
it's over in some sense.
That's one central weakness
of these kinds of informal
institutions.
They rely on the expectation
that I'm going to behave well
in the future.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, if everyone else
is going to pay back in
the future, wouldn't it still
be better for you to default
now if you were being selfish
because the fund's still going
to exist whether or not--
PROFESSOR: No.
But then you can't
borrow again.
Then they can say, look,
you defaulted.
You didn't pay the money
when you needed to.
You were supposed to pay
money into the fund.
You didn't pay.
Now you're out.
But if you come and ask me to
put money into the fund and I
know that everybody else is
planning to default, I'm never
going to do it.
And if I ever get a loan out of
it, I'm going to default as
soon as I can because I
know everybody else
is planning to default.
So in these kinds of
institutions, default is
entirely sort of
self-fulfilling.
So if I expect default,
I'll have default.
If I expect people to behave
well, we'll probably all
behave well.
So probably the reason why
these villages are so
different is because of this
expectation mechanism which is
very important to understand.
And it's true of lots of
financial institutions.
They rely on our future
compliance to work.
And that's why, for example,
even banks to some extent--
if I decide that I'm going to
withdraw my money from the
bank, everybody is going to
withdraw money from the bank
tomorrow, what should
I do today?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I should
withdraw today.
That's a bank run.
So a lot of financial
institutions have
exactly this feature.
And that's why it's not so
surprising to see that some
villages have very good
institutions, rich set of
institutions, others don't.
The fact that some villages
have default,
it's the same reasoning.
Once people start defaulting,
everybody's going to start
defaulting.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could it be possible
that in one village a default
is costlier than in
another village?
Maybe, like, socially you'll
be ostracized or something
like that, and that will help
support the program where
everyone pays into the fund?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So it could very well be that
another thing that this tells
us is that, for example,
a leader matters.
So if the leader is someone who
can enforce punishments in
the village so if I default--
suppose I'm supposed to pay
back, and I know I can pay
back but, you know, I just
refuse to do it.
If the leader can basically have
me ostracized then, in
some sense, I'm not
going to do it.
And then given that I'm not
going to do it, everybody else
is willing to pay
into the fund.
So it's going to be huge
leverage from effective
leadership.
That's the other actually
conclusion of this paper is
that there's a good leader in
the first village, and he was
very important in setting
up these institutions.
He made them work.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was actually
going to ask that.
It seems that you have to
someone who's a good leader in
order to make these
things work.
But what was that guy or girl
doing to keep people confident
of the performance?
PROFESSOR: I can't tell you.
It said that the leader was
very energetic, et cetera.
There's a description of the
leader, but it doesn't tell me
what he was doing so much.
OK, so we already talked
about moral hazard--
other limits of insurance.
But I wanted to emphasize that
because I wanted to emphasize
that this is not just a
limit of insurance.
It's a limit of any institution
that is not
enforced by legal punishments.
Anything that's not enforced
by legal punishments is
fragile always.
It will work if it works.
It doesn't work, it
doesn't work.
That's sort of the main
point of that example.
If we all stop paying money
into the fund then
the fund will die.
So I might as well take
my money and run.
That's true of not just
insurance but of any other
kind of institution.
Now, moral hazard, we've
talked about.
I'm going to skip
moral hazard.
Here's another problem with
informal insurance.
This is all what we've been
talking about a bit.
So we've been sort of talking
about implicitly default.
But we've also been talking
about one thing that an
insurance arrangement demands is
that when it's your time to
pay, you pay.
Sometimes you get money
from the fund.
Sometimes you pay
into the fund.
You have to be willing to
pay money into the fund.
That's what keeps it going.
Why do you want to keep putting
money in the fund?
We said this already,
but just to repeat.
Today I am rich.
I want to put money into the
fund so that somebody else can
take it out.
Why would I want to do it?
Why does anyone want to
put money into a fund?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: To get more
money back.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Eventually you pay me some
return on the fund.
But if it has to have an
insurance component then it
has to be that the return I get
on it is lower than the
market return because otherwise
they could have
borrowed from the market.
It doesn't provide
any insurance.
So it can't be just because I
want to get the money back.
It must be because I expect that
I will be able to borrow
from the fund in the
future as well.
So I will be willing to put
money into a fund which pays
lower than market rate, which
is what insurance is.
Insurance is that I'm willing
to lend to someone at lower
than market rates so that when
he's in bad shape, he doesn't
suffer too much.
That's what's insurance.
AUDIENCE: It's probably also
probably the reason why
wealthier people would be
less likely to give
into a fund, right?
Because they're already exposed
to less risk than they
have already.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: I thought you
said that why would a
rich person do it.
Because I was like, I don't
know why a rich
person would do it.
PROFESSOR: Well, one reason they
may want to do it is that
they feel the same need as--
so what's an insurance fund?
An insurance fund is a fund
where I put in money so that
other people can be helped in
return for the fact that they
will put in money and
I will be helped.
Why would I put in money now?
Because I expect to be
helped in the future.
So what are the kinds of
people who don't want
to join that fund?
You already gave one answer,
which is people who are rich.
They don't expect
to get helped.
So that's why you're going to
see that if there's a lot of
inequality in the village,
you're unlikely to see a fund
because the rich don't really
think that they can be helped
by the poor.
If they ever need money, they're
going to need, you
know, $100,000.
The poor won't have it.
And, otherwise, they
won't need money.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think the chapter
also mentioned
timing as one factor.
I mean, if people always
postpone, they value future
outcomes less than
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you need to be forward
looking to be willing to
behave well and be
forward looking.
If I always think that, well,
I'll just not pay now and
whatever happens in
the future, that's
not going to work.
You need to be forward
looking.
And what's the point
around migration?
Why is migration important?
AUDIENCE: Could you say that as
you have to expect to be in
that area to benefit?
PROFESSOR: In the
villiage, yeah.
You need to be in the village
to benefit from the fund.
If I expect to go away, I don't
know whether I'm going
to be here to benefit
from this fund.
So if there's a lot of mobility
in a place then
everything falls apart.
So villages that are closer to
the road, to a big city, find
it harder to insure
each other.
Why?
Because everybody there has
a link to the city.
So they don't know whether
they're going to help from the
village or they're going
to go to the city
and get a job there.
And so given that I am not
committed to being in the
village, it's very hard
to give me insurance.
So all of these things.
You need low mobility, low
inequality, and forward
looking people.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Also we should say
there are people who have
access to ways to save their
money Right then--
PROFESSOR: That's an
excellent point.
What would a bank account do?
A bank account would undermine
insurance.
Why?
Because in a bank account
I now can get high
return on my savings.
So when I have money, it's more
tempting for me to put it
in the bank account rather
than put it in this fund,
which is going to pay me a
lower return because it's
trying to help out
other people.
So any outside options that
you provide-- so financial
development might undermine
local institutions.
So you might actually see worse
institutions where the
financial system is
better formally.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I misunderstood
the whole fund.
You said that the market rate
was higher than the fund rate.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So even if there was
a bank and you experienced
some hardship, you would
be more inclined to
borrow money from--
PROFESSOR: Oh, absolutely.
It's the other way around.
The question is who do you
borrow money from?
If the bank does it, it makes
it too easy for me.
Today, I have money and
you need money.
I'm going to put my
money in the bank.
That's why you can't get
money from the fund.
The fund is a two way
street, right?
I need to put in money.
You need to take out money.
As my options of putting money
elsewhere get better, it's
going to be harder and harder
to force me to put
money into the fund.
AUDIENCE: Even if the rates at
the other places are higher
than the rates at the fund.
PROFESSOR: Especially, right?
Let me be clear.
What are we saying?
There's a fund.
What's a fund?
The fund is that I put
money into it.
I get lower than market rates.
Why?
Because I want to give that
money to someone else who
needs it desperately,
providing insurance.
There's also a bank, which
pays the market rate.
Now, as the market rate gets
higher, it's harder and harder
for the guy who has money today
to not feel tempted to
put his money into the bank.
Yeah, you had a comment.
AUDIENCE: But, like, there's
a threshold, right?
You have to have a certain
amount of money before you can
open a bank account.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So maybe the bank is not
actually available to you.
But if the bank is available to
you, that might actually be
bad for insurance.
That's sort of maybe surprising
that a bank shows
up and that actually undermines
people's ability to
insure each other because it's
too easy to now park your
money elsewhere.
Other reasons why informal
insurance doesn't work very
well, we've also talked
about the
coordination quite a lot already.
If I expect to default
on the fund then you
will default too.
That's coordination.
Also you would expect that these
funds only work because
I know when you really need
money and when you don't
because otherwise you could
always say I need money.
So you're not letting people
who are very isolated--
so people who are not in the
village network don't get into
these funds.
They tend to be of people who
are relatively well connected
to the village community.
Why?
Because I need to know whether
you're lying or not.
And if you live next to me I
know that, yes, your cow died
or whatever.
Your pig was eaten up by a tiger
or something, whatever
happens to pigs.
But if you live far away, how
do I know whether you are in
trouble or not?
So it tends to be that this is
concentrated among people who
know each other.
The scope of the insurance
is limited.
And, finally, in some sense,
this is a very bad mechanism
for dealing with shocks which
affect everybody in the
village, obviously.
If there is one blight in the
village which affects
everybody, this is not going to
help anybody because nobody
can help each other.
So that takes us back to where
we were at the end of the last
lecture, which is saying on
the other hand, formal
insurance markets are
hard to develop.
That's where we ended
last time.
We said formal insurance markets
are hard to develop.
Why?
Because people are suspicious
of these products.
They don't understand them.
They're too complicated.
They have all these exclusions,
which you don't
understand.
So you don't like it.
I was telling the story of all
of these women who got really
upset because one of their
friend's husband died.
But the medical health insurance
didn't pay for it.
Health insurance was actually
right in not paying for it in
formal terms because their
contract said we'll only pay
for people who go
to the hospital.
He died at home.
But they thought that, well,
something bad happened.
Why aren't you paying for it?
So they basically
got very upset.
So insurance is confusing.
Formal insurance has rules,
which if you [INAUDIBLE]
you don't understand.
It tends to be quite limited
in other ways.
I know a lot about
my neighbors.
I know if his cow was eaten up
by a tiger, for example.
Insurance company doesn't know
anything about my neighbor, so
it can't insure things
like that.
But there's a very nice story.
So cow insurance--
I bring up the example because
it's a good example.
Insuring cows is a big issue
in every developing country
because cows are
a major asset.
In some countries, like in
Botswana, it's the single
biggest asset other than
diamonds, it turns out.
So there only two major
assets in Botswana.
They are cows and diamonds.
But most people have cows.
Very few people have diamonds.
So insurance companies have been
trying for a long time to
insure cows.
The problem is that you insure
cows by saying if the cow
dies, I'll pay you money.
But it's convenient for
cows to die because
they turn into steaks.
And steaks, many people
like them.
So they create a huge moral
hazard problem.
So this company, [INAUDIBLE],
had a very clever idea.
They said that if you claim that
your cow has died, you're
to bring me the ear
of the cow.
Dead cow, you're to cut his
ear off and show it to me.
I don't know.
What happened?
AUDIENCE: A lot of
earless cows?
AUDIENCE: So everytime my cow
died I would start cutting off
ears and creating, like, a
black market [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So imagine my cow dies.
I'm not insured.
What do I do?
I cut off his ear and sell it
to somebody who's insured.
It created a robust market
for cow ears.
Everybody was buying cow
ears to go to the
bank and collect insurance.
So that's your primary problem
with sort of formal insurance.
They don't know where
the cow died.
They have to figure out a
way to track that down.
That's not easy to do because
of this ear problem.
So basically we're between
a rock and a hard place.
People don't understand
insurance.
Insurance is incomplete, at
best, because you can't really
insure cows because
I don't know when
your cow died or not.
On the other hand, if we look
at insurance that comes from
the community, the people who
have the information, that is
too limited for these other
reasons we've discussed.
So we were kind of between
a rock and a hard place.
So I think the message of this
particular area is that this
is a classic area where a
government providing some kind
of insurance that's not expected
to break even is much
more efficient.
So rather than thinking
of insurance
which is market supplied--
for example, a government scheme
which says you can come
to work whenever you need to
work and we'll pay you a
minimum wage is very
effective because
the wage is low enough.
You're not ever going
to take that job if
you have a real job.
You only take it when
you're desperate.
So that's a very efficient
way to provide insurance.
Now, the problem is
that that's not
going to fund itself.
It's a one way payment
from the government.
But on the other hand, it makes
sure that anybody who is
really desperate can
find a job and
therefore it secures them.
So in some terms this
is a classic area--
or if you think of insurance
where people don't understand
the product, well, they don't
want to buy it because they
don't understand the product.
But if you provide it free,
they'll take it.
So if the government were to
actually subsidize insurance,
that might be a very good way
to help poor people because
it's something that they
don't understand
that's good for them.
The demand is too low because
they don't know how to
interpret it.
On the other hand, they will
get the benefits from it.
I think insurance is a very,
very natural place for public
intervention.
And I think that's sort of
what makes it really
interesting is how to design
good insurance products for
poor people which possibly
combine some advantage of the
market and some advantages
of public funding.
So, for example, instead of
the government providing
health care, maybe everybody
should have health insurance
with some appropriately
designed coverage.
And maybe that should be
provided free to people.
If they don't understand the
value of it, that's fine.
In the end, sick people are a
burden of the government.
So they might as well
provide it ex-ante.
Providing a job to everybody--
work fair is the word people
use in the US--
to people who want a job is a
way to make sure that people,
when they're desperate, there's
some way of generating
income and that the wage at that
income doesn't go down
because everybody's
demanding a job.
So in some sense it's a
way to secure people.
And it's a way to do it
efficiently, to make sure that
the right people go to it.
You don't want to
give them money.
You want to give them a job
because a job has the
advantage that you
get targeted.
So in some sense it's a
good domain to think
about public policy.
I'll stop here.
We might talk a little bit
more about it later.